it's that time of year again NFL 15 the
15th NFL game ser bem SE madden is he
still around yeah I thought think I rid
of them when they got rid of Tiger Woods
on the golf games madden 15 are you
ready for some football football I'm
ready for you Europeans call it American
football my friend Eric take handball
you doing doing all right very nice of
you to wear the miners we lost the Super
Bowl Jersey you know we discussed this
the other day granted you've been doing
your half life half marathon yeah uh
that you were gonna wear jersey I was
and you know this would look you know
less awkward yeah but it's okay i will
represent 49ers wants to go on gamespot
com where the host war strictly sports
jerseys and no one ever thought that's a
good point no it was literally on right
here yeah Richie Rich gallop behind that
wall God rest his soul but we're gonna I
guess you're gonna be the miners I like
the others I'm gonna be a team befitting
the Niners and who should be are you in
traction tires you're gonna go for a
conquer move I feel like the zone yet
there's only one team i can pick
steelers are a 90 100 i can convey be
likes a poon we're definitely not all
mad and you won't you want to impress be
you guys are definitely wear shoes and
exact same teams that problem and i
played as I think we should grow you go
pro I'm not gonna oh you can go rookie
yeah that's good too ok we'll go pro all
right let's take one one quarter yeah
I'll Venice there like that in 52
probably two quarters in yeah and a half
half egg Tay what's different about this
year's how it madam game do the easier
one mm-hmm what try going left yeah
whatever we'll figure it out yeah I
think there's a more of an emphasis on
defense now okay you're going to see as
you know if you guys didn't watch the
stream earlier so we're going to explain
some of these what if you did bear with
me there's going to be some Q ups you
know like if you're on the defensive
line you can actually like you know
press X or a it'll kind of trigger for
you to you know press that button like
almost like a quick time event yeah and
that'll help you you know do a swim
moves when we were like a shed that's
shed the tackle so that you can pass
rush the quarterback mm-hmm and so what
you're telling me is they've changed
very
cific things about this game like last
year that's always the way they do it
man yeah a little the other thing that
so we had this live stream on earlier i
was chatting with a pro madden player
and eric problem right and he was saying
it's more great more of a defensive
based game this year like he was saying
quarterbacks will now like have more
errant throws that don't just go to two
opposing we're defending to space they
go somewhere else they they have a wider
range of error so you want to be looking
at your stats for like four different
paths accuracies a little bit more yeah
and defense definitely a bit of an
influence this time around I mean you
got I mean Richard Sherman on the cover
and the stuff Eric was talking about at
the line and all right well we'll see
that when the game starts this and we're
good as presentation-wise looks great
real good ya headin last year I can
tweet mock turtlenecks Jim Harbaugh yeah
hardball gonna be screaming is goddamn
face off I can do that i'll do it for
him okay yeah lubar gonna go home or go
out here yeah it's kind of yellow I
don't have the khakis on saying I
already listening it's not what's on
your body is what's in your heart okay
so i just got in your body it comes out
of your body in the form of anger words
God and maybe some spittle all right
okay like clipboards that you just lie
still with vomit out onto the field
let's go bug that's really good there we
go hey Eric does your team and have a
song that was written by Prince no all
right well you can suck it Danny why did
you choose the Vikings my buddy del
canto back home and Ireland is a big
Minnesota Vikings fan and matt cassel's
us and what they're putting real video
of people's faces in here and I went to
both em at games in wembley in England
last year and the one of them was the
Vikings against the redskins on actually
won it was the second only one of two
games they want to think of it regular
is one more than two given so was your
offensive plan give ball to Adrian
Peterson and then just sit back and
watch yep I'm gonna give it to Greg
Janie's you got the team on the back
going in
so uh I don't know if you noticed it but
like when you hiked it like I was
telling me the right trigger like right
away oh really yeah I'll try to like
we'll see if it comes up again they'd it
Rumble or did it just get rumbles okay
rumbles and then it's like if you had
the reactions it'll be like perfect or
like fair right we're like poor kind of
what numbers greg james again 1881 right
no yeah it might be Oh see it said late
there oh goodness he's on his back he
got it I wasn't that I wasn't destined i
know i'm gonna say for every single time
I Benson pulling it down he's got that
catching in traffic stead and music
playback balance looking bounced off the
other guy's helmet he held on to it that
was like why do you think I'd never play
a madden game and I 34 stands in a row
he is mark come on man I'm Harlan you
don't even this game is so far and we
refer to it with the country name first
fair enough identify here's your weights
will you call in here american madden
NFL 15 exactly gonna call notable gun
double flags East Lance let's see some
hot routes up in here not route hot
route my corner needs to follow him he's
not quick all again if yep this so stop
messing with me man cast trying to go
come on you forgot I'm delay of game oh
well I've had just so hike the ball
folks what a victory here for this
Vikings offense all right oh man with
that kind of tenacity there's no way the
niners gonna be able to stop him they
were able to hike the ball hey Beck that
got a team cohesiveness you really need
to succeed in the NFL these days are you
sure the game knew he was talking crap
to me so you know oh really you got a
little tired of what I'm so happy that
you're one success was that I didn't I
couldn't hike the ball Oh see you said
perfect Oh
ah oh I brought the jersey mmm who is
that number 99 get out of my castle boy
hey get out of my castle all right I
always thought was great demo surely i'm
sure they told me in the chat 15 15 all
right now he knows we're gonna throw the
boy he's gonna pass the ball I don't
care he's it boys that's too late he's
on beat Oh Greg Jennings great that's
great that's what I want to be good
throw wannabes Brodin baby sweet spot so
the question is do you do the team
building thing or are you gonna go for
the I know getting there oh it's a
54-yard er though it's pretty far but i
gotta whose if you're kicking skills are
as good as chris is here ya SE for
yarder might as well be a 17-yard ER or
a million guys really making it Oh sugar
all right you don't even look like it's
gonna make it pull it back and then push
it forward when the meter goes a top
part of the meter oh god this is I
really should have practiced this at
least once oh I get it way better than I
am short that is definitely short all
right good way better than my earlier
efforts Danny Bridgewater you suck TP
all right Colin and his sweet attention
or settle that problem where the tattoo
artists were like yo I don't be using
our art in your video game I think Colin
Kaepernick's you got approved though
looks like they I think they came out
and he's the only tattooed player in the
NFL were like forty-eight percent of
players are tattooed perhaps in this
game they look real good I don't know
about you but they look pretty good I
don't know I'd have to see a side by
side had the same problem with CM Punky
as he had the Pepsi logo taco did it
yeah why did he have the Pepsi logo test
straight edge we awesome was that some
Peter more action oh please catch that
like in his youth he was a spokesman for
Pepsi he tried to like make he went all
in on a Pepsi bid and it's didn't work
out he did one of those competitions or
if you get the Pepsi tattoo logoed on
your hat on your arm you got a year's
free worth of Pepsi do you remember that
when they went Torok came out really
with torques two or three kim as they
had a thing where if you changed your
name to turok you got like ten thousand
dollars and some dude did it yeah it was
like named know Torok Smith no
yeah oh my goodness for 10 grand and I
was probably be like 10 grand before
that is super weird yeah if you name
your child turok will give you 10 grand
I'd be worse I like the part of the run
where Gore just went let his body go
limp in the back of another one on a
back of his blocker I liked it like a
little fish wiggle he's like take me
take me forward oh yeah hey why don't
you pick one that you don't suck so hard
up come on man Danny hit a fire zone
pick what they don't suck it so much
come on look the lines right there six
why don't you listen he's just burn it
you just eaten up the clock worrying
about it and let me just I didn't
realize it was gonna be a six-minute
quarter you guys should probably just
play one quarter burning Davis Oh flag
yeah no holding here cuz your whole
team's got BD vineri like that was one
of those new defensive fouls that the
refs personal all the time face mask a
white face mask hands to the face dammit
why you Emma meung me which button did I
really except that which one's the fake
the face masking button it's like
impressive do you want you to connect
you need connect for that oh and then
you just put your face in front your
hand in front of your buddies face you
can't see me that would be cool is this
John Cena that would be cool if connects
like enabled in game like you know if
you are jostling them or like whacking
their controller and it could it would
track that and then hat make in-game
things happen that would be good for the
next mutant league football game that
they make that remake with mu nu lu
football man that's a long
mmm in a long time since a mutant league
I'm not a big mountain guy but I didn't
play a lot of bad blitz the league was
good too this is pretty good as in i
only played that one where you could
shatter people's testicles oh oh that
one minus one yeah let's get the air to
study one it was good fun oh no way no
way bro Oh cutting it back to the
midfield we don't know a dog's way to
find some negative yards there yeah I
was trying to style and didn't know that
that was going to do the spin back wish
I thought I was gonna do a little cut
jump I jump cut like this in an orthodox
move he decided to run back towards I
want the good chance you know third and
nine for this Niner squad handily picked
up the thought last third down situation
there one for one or maybe two for two I
haven't been keeping that close track oh
then I'm going to psych him out psych
him out with some cult from play-calling
oh that's a pic Oh rolls into traffic oh
I'm gonna like a diamond I really would
like one of you guys to get some points
during okay all right buku buku see a
form of a dramatic touchdown that you do
by faking this field goal bacon it is he
faking it take it or make it well Dawson
strong leg Dawson that looks good Adam
and it is that's three for the San
Francisco 49ers over the Minnesota
Viking man's how we do it it's very
unexcited but we play for the w i'm
gonna kick your ass that's my oxide
receive you totally onside receive yeah
I don't need I don't need a defense whoo
all right where's the Hail Mary button
oh you've got you've got to work the
clock man you got a minute 30 left yeah
you said you want manager to quarters or
one quarter just one quarter one quarter
that's right he's got an only 32 unless
you guys want to want to extend it we'll
see how about if you if we minute 32 is
just enough time to get to touch down
hahaha he's dropping back throws off his
back but it's into the railing
like four dudes in san francisco de how
do you guys not intercept that now is
like a jump ball you guys free you guys
Patrick Willis of you gentlemen Eric
Reid is this showing all of the 49ers
that were closer to that passed and then
Vikings receiver pretty much they should
do that thing where they tell what they
have them say what universities there
from and then they make up fake
universities like all so hard University
Kraken Kraken Hogwarts was probably the
best one or a man hey Ron if I said that
when it was news one of the names was a
Donnie who was the guy you said bowl so
hard University and I remember right who
was the guy who said cret his name was
crap Rankin anyone Hogwarts I forget his
name how quickly our memories fade which
gonna Google crackin Hogwarts me third
and ten Danny the hopes of an entire
frigid northern central state in the
United States of America stall you know
way more I got it you seen us you got
that pic juicer doc it's not a pic if
your honor all right I'm under receiver
you I don't know your terminology I've
only been watching this board for like
nine months I can't you see that slam
dunk slam three points baby chick oh my
goodness that was cracking hot road yeah
very good on the Panthers Greg hardy reg
Hardiman crackin Hogwarts oh yeah thanks
sitting on eggs yeah yeah all that field
I hit the wrong button alright that was
as good as my spin move here's negative
yards oh yeah you didn't say that I saw
all of it he didn't see that
oh my goodness I was legitimately afraid
just throwing terrible passes there's
not one person on the stream that
doesn't hope that I don't catch this
that's true everyone's hoping everyone
is saying Hail Marys or whatever their
preferred josh says we're gonna end it
after this Josh will end it when I'm
winning well any when I hail the Mary I
gotta say my prayers oh no oh yeah take
a bum look at the fumble air agree take
them with you god damn it at least
someone knows it's only one second Josh
we're not leaving are you American do
your hand marriott you better hail there
I'll set everyone up front real stupidly
all right I'll go goal wanna go special
teams yeah just give one person back
there to begin to play can I do it can I
do a punt return I feel like you're
gonna get to me before the hell marry
I'm gonna blitz you all right I still
feel like I'm gonna get hit before you
don't get this you come on Kaepernick's
got that speed rating your name is
Brandon Lloyd on his own yeah also gonna
battle one of the players immediately
okay danny is jamming on the face mask
button Oh doll come on you shoulda used
a little oomph break tackle there okay
I'm nine outs I'll time it yeah see how
you get it emphatically real I'm here to
score more points well we discuss this
already yeah we did that's true hey guys
that lets work so good last time let's
just do it again it's Boyd holding our
is gonna sit everyone Stevie we're just
gonna force the Stevie see him Stevie oh
there it is Stevie I'm gonna talk a lot
guy Oh is going for the corner thanks
Danny sweet dance show me the leg wiggle
Stevie what's that dudes name give me
console word former Buffalo Bill traded
I think a fourth round for him boom ran
up the yeah very unnecessary there yeah
you look you didn't just jump backwards
like it did last time I made sure we run
out of bounds at the pile on I made sure
if anyone is interested in more of
delicious madden 15 action of course you
guys did a stream earlier this morning
yeah that'll be up on the site it's a
long stream with a madden pro player
lots of questions answered lots of
insights into what makes this year's mad
slightly different than the other than
previous years what some new sort of
tweaks are from the perspective of
someone who plays a crap ton of madden
cool also i think the review hopefully
today it sweet is what they're aiming
for but if not today or tomorrow Madden
said today right yes fantastic all right
thanks very much guys coming on and play
and apologies to everyone all my
minnesota brethren a4a for doing a bad
losing losing badly